[Music]
we brought together seven white people I
am white I am white I am white I am
white I am white I am white I am black
one is a liar while blindfolded
if the group discovers who the liar is
they'll split a cash prize
if the liar survives she wins the entire
prize
I got walked into the box I was really
scared but I was really confident that I
was gonna win because I practice also I
have a naturally white voice clearly I'm
not white
Elizabeth custom cakes I'm eating sound
white but that booty though that moody
cocoa butter let's go my task in this
game was to be as white as possible I
think my tactic was just to try to be as
friendly as possible you know what
happen there right thank you
you know what happened there right I'm
not crazy you know what happened there
right
you know why we're laughing you know
when you said that while we're laughing
you know right I don't think we need
this baby just in case so let me get
this sweet this is a game where people
are trying to figure out who's the black
parts in the group and who's white and
you're going to convey the fact that
you're not the black person by being
nice my intuition tells me oh this is
gonna be 10 minutes or white people
trying to not seem Rossi's and they're
gonna fail I'm gonna stick to whatever I
said alright you know why we laugh right
you know they're probably got it but for
the ones who did it the ones in the back
the ones in the back I was going based
off names
what's your last name mariah ford like
the car what about a truck or like the
truck in town like the car wait that's
crazy
wait you said your last name is pinto
like like the bean I mean for people
that don't see color they're sure from
raras funny
I think there's a bit of a culture that
I mean of course there's a lot more of a
culture than I think that black people
have that white people don't what do you
think that we'll only wants to have
culture you've never heard of Irish
people you've never heard of Italians
you've never heard of Greeks you've
never heard of most of the countries in
Europe even Americans have their own
form of white culture what kind of what
kind of music do you guys listen to
Justin Bieber
I love she's going for she's going for
the gold she's like if I just say the
most stereotypical wide stuff well it
might be a good strategy no what about
like like red hot chili pepper isn't
like wait the Red Hot Chili Peppers
singing sing like tonight tonight
tonight look it's not the song but the
whole point is like she doesn't know the
music that she's really yeah what but
you know I mean I can name you five
songs red hot I'll let you have real hot
chili pepper soup I mean Californication
Joe great a great song hmm that music
video for California keishon mm-hmm
musics it is when he's like this like
the video game going through all these
videos were the crazy it was actually
really hard to try and figure out who it
was just based on like the voices and
the things that they would say
Kylee that was the name that I felt my
opinion like I was pretty sure I was
right they're all walking on eggshells
with what they're saying yeah feel it
yeah I don't know why but I just feel
like kylie is not the widest name of
everyone that i've heard it feels like
hrs trying to tell
roshanda that she's a little loud so the
way she does listen what people at the
office have told me is that the way your
energy comes off just not jiving in
reality is like she's just a crazy she
doesn't say it because she doesn't want
to see luck so what you saying
Juliet not me but it came to my
attention that maybe yeah you could try
to emulate the ambience of the room you
work with yeah
and in order to do that which I love
your hair
I really just one drink it if you could
jizz yeah switch it up you look they're
all doing the by kylie by i guess
because of my name I don't think that I
really like said enough to like have a
solid vote now what did you got in I
think this is the burning question that
we've all been thinking what did you
guys think of Black Panther cuz a lot of
people said it was good I wish it was a
little bit more gory that was very
popular among people of color is a great
movie
I loved it if you watch black panther
that doesn't make you white or black
like that was a huge movie one person
saw a black panther and a lot of people
did but I I did that for a goof oh I've
seen Black Panther disclaimer loved
Black Panther it was iconic
I didn't say Black Panther she was that
money yes I meant like no no nobody
knows I'm gonna Millie right now yeah I
was shocked I think it was the yoga
comment why people do yoga - come on I
do yoga - it was just horrible timing
so I'll start since I'm at the end now
where Ana what's this is Brandon wait so
is the mall gone that's what I kind of
thought it was Kylie hey Brandon okay a
cop pulls you over what do you do it
literally just happened to me like two
weeks ago was it for speeding
it was the baggage you saw the privilege
you could smell it no it was actually my
front license plate he's like I'm just
gonna give you a warning it really
bothers me that I'm like when somebody
is actually getting pulled over for
doing something and they're not getting
ticketed but somebody you have another
race could get pulled over for the same
thing and they would get a ticket you
know give you a warning Vick yeah he
gave me a warning you're white if I were
to be honest I've gotten followed home
in my town so many times and they're
doing it because I'm one of few black
people in my hometown and they they
should know me by now like there's a few
of us come on
[Applause]
I knew it guys who's Brandon Brandon I
beef with you
you're onto me from the start you're
Elizabeth no no you keep saying like it
was witness like the waters name ever
heard it's not it's almost as if like
this guy didn't know that all these
countries colonized a whole bunch of
different countries and gave black
people whole bunch of white names my
last name from Belgium what's your first
name Eric what a me how many black guys
with the name James do I know your Jim
so I don't know why you would think
inherently that Elizabeth is a white
name always to say you know what's funny
about watching a video to me was just
watching them walking on eggshells
yeah old time the thing is this I how do
you decipher if someone is black
stereotypes right but they didn't want
to say but they didn't want to say that
because they're gonna look right well I
mean so that's pretty much it
yes they were like no we're talking
about HR right there yeah that was
really HR 10 minutes of them going to be
like how can I get this person without
seeing what do y'all think about fried
chicken you know it came to my attention
that some of the rules and this is not
just you it's just I'm gonna do
everybody personally just we have to we
have to abide by the rules of the
cafeteria
then we when you when we microwave now
you who me when when we as a team we
have appears here when we microwave food
we have to there are certain spices that
oh yeah you know it's always interesting
is when like their stereotypes come out
but there are positive stereotypes and
so they don't feel as I guarded about
yeah
so I oh I like dancing like oh yeah you
seem like the type that would like
dancing and how would I look like the
type you look like the type that will do
my taxes those are always 20 moments I
probably would have referred this video
if they would have just been very honest
about whatever stereotypes yes you know
but you're not the norm it's a residue
people I mean the backlash no fear they
would be career self deletion exactly
career-ending type of video you know
sometimes we do videos about certain
people and after the words they call us
they contact us and be like yo can you
do something about that video because
it's causing me problems it's causing me
problems if you did that competition do
you think you'd win ah good chances
would you ask I don't know what I would
ask is more in my answers I could ask
the same thing but I could just you know
you have to eliminate them all let's say
was five black people in there to
deliver decipher who's white
mm-hmm what would you ask the white
person to discover if they're white or
not talk to me about your your childhood
hmm but they could lie they could make
it up absolutely it's just in how they
lie sometimes it's how they're gonna
life so I'm not gonna look at your
answer I'm gonna look at how you answer
it hmm and is there a hesitation about
it you know what I mean that that's
really much what it is I'm mad at you
but just put the name I mean my name was
hmm
can I get around white people's oh and
that's why he told that that white girl
that girl led chose a girl that could
blendin blandin doing yeah do you
wouldn't be that difficult I know
because you sound like Romano sure
Deborah Deborah
all right cool sure so anyways that's it
for today's video
tell us if you guys got in comments
below we want to hear
[Music]
you